in just a couple of moments a very
special day around major league baseball
we celebrate 100 years of negro league
history
and a very special first pitch today the
son of satchel page
robert page
go marlin
it's a strike there's no doubt about it
it's a strike that is fantastic again so
much baseball history
has gone through the negro league some
of the greatest players to ever play
this game
at any level in any league played in the
negro league so we are
excited in order to give you some of
that history throughout the day again
miami giants uniforms that the marlins
are wearing this afternoon a semi-pro
team that played in the 30s and 40s
at dorsey park in overtown miami on the
mound for the marlins is eliezer
hernandez third start of the season
first start at marlins park in nearly a
year and that will bring up nick
marcakis
and hernandez gets marquis is swinging
robbie erlin who pitches for the second
time
as a brave his first start of the season
here for the braves
one down here in the bottom of a
scoreless first inning for jesus
aguilard
and he chased one asks if it was a
strike it wouldn't have been
and that's the second out in the second
for the braves it'll be
deval comes back with the slider there
gets duvall
and that's his second strikeout one away
johan camargo
three homers and six rbis you get
increased playing time with ozzy albies
on the il
hernandez with another strikeout that's
three in a row going back to the first
and it's up to tyler flowers to avoid a
one two three second inning
here's the pitch oh two swing and a
missed strike three
struck out the side he did eliezer
hernandez nice work so far
and nothing across for the braves here
in the second inning
lee wendy has lewis brinson and john
bertie coming up
one two pitch breaking ball swung on and
missed
second strike out of the afternoon for
robbie irland
three call princeton frozen three
strikeouts for erlang you can tell he
knows what he's doing
for six couple of strikeouts in the
series right-handed batter
and another strikeout for eliezer
hernandez
make it five so ryan lavarnway former
red sox
and former braves catcher so now the
payoff pitch
and lavon way chased that that's four
strikeouts for erlang boy the soft stuff
is
working well early in the game that's a
big strike out there
next up is monty harrison payoff
did he go yes he did and i think the
answer is yes a high strike takes care
of harrison for the second out that's
five strikeouts for ireland
here's marcelo zuna a 2-2 to ozuna swing
and a miss on the fastball so
six strikeouts for hernandez hell
sliders early fastballs late and getting
the job done at the top of the zone we
continue to see it
climbs the ladder and beats ozuna
adams struck out his first time up on o2
duvalla swinging and missed that was a
slider again he doubled up on it
and he's got his seventh strikeout
through four innings you're looking
inside
the negro league baseball museum in
kansas city
lots and lots of great stuff there the
president of
that said museum is bob kendrick camargo
here then tyler flowers and then austin
riley
that pitch is called strike three caught
the outside
and camargo's gone for the second time
by the strikeout route and that is
eight and now donny's going to come get
his money's worth he is not a happy
camper
this is three series worth of
frustration with this crew boiling over
yes i think this has to do with balls
and strikes
donnie continues to make whatever points
he wants to make with this umpiring crew
for donnie it's the 33rd time he's been
ejected in
now 10 seasons as a big league manager
number 14 in his five years
with the marlins and that pitch was a
strike and you go from two and two
potentially to three and one that
changes in it back
which could change a game when you're
0-0 in the fifth inning
tyler flowers aboard in front of austin
riley
swinging a miss by riley that's nine
strikeouts he's struck out twice in the
game
in the lineup today for the braves riley
camargo
and duvall each have struck out twice
for the top of the order swanson freeman
and ozuna get a look at a new marlin
there's a fly ball hammered toward left
late jump
and princeton can't get it and dansby's
around first on his way to second that
wasn't played very well by louis brinson
so break for atlanta lead off double and
the braves have their first real threat
of the game
little flare into right center field
it's going to drop behind forsyth
marcakus comes through with a two-strike
hit
it wasn't hard hit but it was perfectly
placed and the braves had broken through
where would the braves be without nick
marcakis in 2020
he's got to throw a strike at the braves
get a run the pitch
he missed badly in sight after getting
ahead in the count and it's a
basis-loaded walk for ozuna
give him his 13th rbi and the braves
extend the lead
so now it's marcakis braves have walked
three times and this one's hit hard to
right field that's off the wall
dansby's gonna score freeman's coming
around third he's gonna score
it's a double for nick marcakis and the
braves have blown the game open
jonathan vr the battery
and the o2 pitch on the way half swing
he went
ball game the braves able to blank the
marlins
matsik with a one two three nine
thinning with the two strikeouts
and the braves take the series two games
to one to finish the road trip
on the right way